johanna jogs along a straight path for
zero is less than or equal to t is less
than or equal to 40 johanna's velocity
is given by a differentiable function v
selected values of v of t where t is
measured in minutes and v of t is
measured in meters per minute are given
in the table above we see that right
over there use the data in the table to
estimate the value of not v of 16 v
prime of 16. and we see here they don't
even give us v of 16. so how do we think
about v prime of 16.
well just just remind ourselves this is
the rate of change of v with respect to
time when time is equal to 16. so we can
estimate it and that's the key word here
estimate we can estimate v prime of 16
by thinking about what is our change in
velocity over our change in time around
16. and when we look at it over here
they don't give us v of 16 but they give
us v of 12 they give us v of 20. so
let's figure out our rate of change
between 12 t equals 12 and t equals 20.
so our change in velocity that's going
to be v of 20
minus v whoops v of 20 minus v of 12
and then our change in time
is going to be 20
minus 12. and so this is going to be
equal to v of 20 is 240
240 v of 12 we see right there is 200
and so this is going to be 40
over 8 which is equal to 5 and we would
be done it's oh for good measure it's
good to put the units there so this is
our rate this is how fast the velocity
is changing with respect to time so the
units are going to be meters per minute
per minute so we could write this as
meters
per minute squared
per
minute
meters per minute squared and we're done
now if you want to get a little bit more
of a visual understanding of this and
what i'm about to do you would not
actually have to do on the actual exam
well let's let's just try to graph
let's graph these points here let me
give myself some
space to do it
so if we were if we tried to graph it
so i'll just do a
very rough graph here
so let's say this is y is equal to v of
t
and we see that v of t goes as low as
negative 220 goes as high as 240.
so let me give so i want to draw the
horizontal axis someplace around here
t is positive
so it looks something like that and so
let's just make
let's make this
let's make that
200 and
and so then this would be
200 and 100
200 and 100 there and that would be
negative 100 and that would be negative
200 and then that would be
negative
300 and we see on the t-axis or our
highest value is 40 we go between 0 and
40.
and so these obviously aren't at the
same scale
but this is going to be 0. if we put 40
here
and then if we put 20 in between
and so this would be 10.
let me do a little bit to the right that
would be 10 and then that would be
30. and so what points do they give us
so they give us
i'll do these in orange
zero comma zero so that is right
over there
they give us when time is 12 our
velocity is 200
so when the time is 12 which is right
over there our velocity is going to be
so that's that point
when our time is 20 our velocity is
going to be 240.
so when our time is 20 our velocity is
240 which is going to be right over
there
and then when our time is 24 our
velocity is negative 220. so she
switched directions so one is 24 so 24
is going to be roughly over here
it's going to be negative 220 so
negative 220 might be right over there
and then finally when time is 40 her
velocity is 150 positive 150.
so at 40 it's
positive
150. and so these are just sample points
from her velocity function but what we
wanted to do is we wanted to find in
this problem we want to say okay when t
is equal to 16
when t is equal to
16 what is the rate of change and we
don't know much about we don't know what
v of 16 is but what we could do is and
this is essentially what we did in this
problem we could say all right well we
can approximate what the function must
might do by roughly drawing a line here
so if you draw a line there and you say
all right well v of 16 or v prime of 16
i should say
so v prime of 16 is going to be
approximately the slope
is going to be approximately the slope
of
this line that's going to be our best
job based on the data that they've given
us of estimating the value of v prime of
16. so we literally just did change in v
which is that one delta v
over change in t
over
over delta t to get the slope of this
line which is our best approximation for
the derivative when t is equal to 16.